the ron desantis story just keeps
getting more and more insane let me re
reset this for you
uh the last time up until recently that
ron desantis the uh republican truck
very trumpy in florida governor ron
desantis was seen in public was december
17th
on december 17th he showed up at
baygalicious delhi and bakery in oak in
ocala
and he took a picture this is from the
begalicious delian bakery page on
facebook
dated december 17th they posted even the
governor loves bagalicious so this was
the last time he was seen in public and
nearly two weeks went by nearly two
weeks went by and then
all of a sudden
the desantis people came out and said oh
he was with his wife at her cancer
treatment ron desantis wife
is being treated for breast cancer and
our thoughts of course are with her and
we hope that the treatment goes well
uh but that is the explanation for why
he was missing for two weeks didn't
really make sense because apparently
that was only on december 29th that he
was with her
it then got even weirder
because on december 30th the ron
desantis official twitter account posted
the very same picture
of desantis at the bagelicious as if it
was that day
had some great bagels from bagelicious
in ocala stop by if you're in the area
so
understand that
it's very weird
this is the last public picture of
desantis anywhere we know the picture is
from december 17th because bagalicious
posted it on december 17th and then on
the 30th after
tons of people saying where is this guy
covet is exploding it's complete in
total chaos he's m.i.a he says no look
here i'm out in public but they post a
picture that is 13 almost 14 days old
okay so that's all really really weird
but then this is just the worst part of
it and this is this is just sad i don't
know how else to say it this is just sad
um
there is now video
of ron desantis
at a huge concert on new year's eve
with his wife who has cancer
unmasked
um
everybody should assess risk for
themselves of course you know it's
your wife has cancer
we have an insanely contagious variant
florida is setting case records every
single day and you go to a massive event
without masks i mean what are you what
what are you doing that this is
dangerous to her take a look at this and
so in florida you can mark it down we
will not let anyone shut you down
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are going to make sure that our
rights are respected and that's what
we've done and that's what we'll
continue to do so i hope you all have a
very very good
2022
i think there's going to be a lot of
good things on the horizon and
we're looking forward to being able to
do a lot for the state looking forward
for my wife to beat breast cancer which
is gonna happen
[Applause]
and so thank you and
keep
fighting all right so you get it i mean
listen we all hope that she beats breast
cancer
bringing her in the middle of peak cove
it unmasked to a huge event where we
have a prevalence where by by some
estimates
12 to 18 percent of the country
currently has coveted
um
seems incredibly unwise but just a very
strange story missing for almost two
weeks says well i'm missing because i
was with my wife at cancer treatment
except when you look that was only on
the 29th posts a picture from two weeks
earlier saying hey here i am in public
and then you show up unmasked at this
everything about this guy disgusts me
and that certainly doesn't change with
this latest episode